because if you talk to a friend right
you know everything there is scenario
like you know yeah what you would tell
your friend
you're like yeah girl you need to leave
um
i i don't know what you're thinking he's
obviously
you know you could do so much better and
you know then the tables get turned
and you're there acting it all out this
is kind of what i reacted to earlier
when i was fumbling around um and then
the tables get turned on you
and someone says to you danica
what would you say to me
if i said all these things and i was
like oh [ __ ]
you gotta go yeah i believe that each
and every one
of us has the power within ourselves to
create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense today's guest
is neshwa zabian she is a poet
an author a speaker she is
wise beyond her years she's 29 years old
she was born in lebanon
but lives in canada now and her
insightfulness
into life and the experiences that we
have
and the self-reflection that she's been
able to generate
and grow from um just her awareness
for human nature and how to heal is
really really
impressive um i'm just so impressed with
with neshwa and i've been following her
for years
her poems are so powerful it's amazing
what one sentence of hers
can make you feel so i i just thoroughly
enjoyed the conversation that we had
uh public live in front of an audience
which was a totally different setting
so we we just talked about uh the
struggles that go on in life
and the things that we are all dealing
with and i just very much appreciate her
vulnerability and honesty
uh and really look forward to just
becoming better friends with her so i
hope you enjoyed today's episode
i remember seeing you on social media
and you were
you were in your car and you were
talking to your phone and your car
and i just thought that the words that
you were saying were so
meaningful and you the the feeling that
you were portraying in them were so deep
and i just was compelled by it so
it's been a long time since i feel like
those were your videos
right but you still do them every now
and again yeah can you take me back
to the uh the girl
in the car recording videos a couple of
years ago
yeah so that was me probably after
a long day of teaching when i had so
many thoughts in my mind or
right before i went to teach in the
morning
when my thoughts were just fresh and i
needed to get something out
and that was just my way of journaling
in a way
like in a very private manner but
putting it out to this world that no one
else around me
like belonged to so
it was just an intensity of thoughts and
feelings that i felt i had to somehow
put out there and i didn't really care
about the format
like i didn't care about sitting in
front of a professional camera
and and just waiting until then i just
needed to get it out right there
was that the beginning of sharing
publicly
the beginning was on instagram
probably a few months before sharing
videos from
my car i remember the very first video
i was sitting in our backyard and
i would i started it by saying
um so maybe you're a little too
sensitive
or maybe when you love you give too much
love
maybe when you care about someone you
give them a little too much
care but what does too much even mean
i remember that was my very first video
and
people reacted to it so well and
i think now they got to see me in a
different way like they had always read
my writings and they'd seen them
being typed out in videos but they'd
never seen
me in action so so that's what started
it
yeah so that was the first time that
there was like
the automated the verbal version versus
the uh written version yes how early was
the written version
out for the public to see that would
have been
three years ago so i would say three to
four months before i started putting
videos out there yeah but before that
i had been writing for three years
so i started writing at 23
and then at 26 i put out my first
collection of writing
mind platter and yeah a few months after
that i started putting out videos
and i still do them from my car
sometimes
now sometimes sometimes yeah
but now i'm i'm more likely to sit in my
office in a
well-lit corner and just put my phone in
front of me and speak to it
i still do that yeah yeah is it like
therapy yes many times and i think
many people don't realize this is when i
sit in front of
the camera to say something more often
than not i'm saying it to myself first
before i say it to anyone
else so if i'm going through a difficult
time where
say i'm feeling very weak or i'm feeling
like i'm just not myself and i'll start
the video by saying
if you're feeling weak or if you're
feeling like you're not yourself this is
what i want you to remember
and i would say the message to myself
but also to others at the same time yeah
that's so
very therapeutic thank you
i remember i was making a i was asked to
make
a self video of
how i felt about my last race the indy
500 in 2018
and it was it's for my documentary
and um i didn't even want to do that
like i felt vulnerable too vulnerable to
do that that i was like i just
i don't like talking to the camera i
don't get it i don't
what i just didn't feel comfortable so
there's such a level of
bravery do you recognize that that
you're you're
basically journaling to the public
does it feel like well we all have
feelings like we all go through things
i'm i'm past the point in my life where
i want people to look at me and say oh
neshwa is so strong
all the time i'm not i'm not there i
truly believe that you can be a strong
person
and still have moments of doubt you can
be a strong person and still have a
moment
of vulnerability you can be a strong
person
and still be braving
and becoming strong through something
like you don't reach that point where
you say yeah i've overcome
so many things in my life and that's it
and to me
if i'm telling everyone out there be
yourself
and be vulnerable and
be authentic then i have to be my
authentic self too
i i don't believe in leading just by
words i believe that you have to put
your words to action and that's what i'm
doing so
sometimes you'll see me you know with
barely any makeup on and my hair is
still curly and sometimes you'll see me
all done up and
that's just me showing every part of who
i am
you know and i just i just know
you know before i think i used to
worry so much about just a few
select people like what is he gonna
think or what is she gonna think if i
put up this video or this post
and over time someone asked me a
question
i think it was last year saying like
don't you worry about
what your critics think or don't you
worry about
you know those who don't have the same
beliefs that you have and i said
but i'm not here to amplify their voice
if i stay quiet and hide myself because
i'm worried about what the critics will
say
then i'm amplifying their voice i said i
amplify the voice of the girl or the boy
who's sitting in that dark corner
who doesn't have anyone who can say i
understand or let me help you up
that's whose voice i amplify and so
if my focus is that i really don't care
about what the critics will say or what
those who don't believe that
vulnerability is the way or authenticity
is the way and
i just i don't focus on them anymore
confidence um so
who was that girl back then if you were
to describe that girl that was 2017 i
think
i think that was 2 000 yeah over two
years ago yeah
yeah yeah so sort of like give me the
snapshot
of nashua then
um she was very scared
she was feeling very small
and like her voice
didn't matter at all to anyone or
anything
she was
very hard on herself and put
literally everyone else ahead of her
and
in a way she didn't really know who she
was
at all um she defined herself
by you know the praise she got after a
job well done
and defined herself by how much she was
able to give
and that's it not by who she was at all
and
she got to a point where she couldn't
even
she would look in the mirror and not
recognize who she was looking at
that's very self-reflective and
powerful to be able to recognize those
things
we tend to not want to say the things
about ourselves that aren't so
fantastic but i'm going to bet that's
because you've overcome a lot of those
things and you're working through
a lot of those things but before we talk
about
some of those specifics like some
specific
topics that are very interesting to me
about growth
um i want to talk about where you grew
up so you grew up in lebanon
yeah i was born and raised there you
were born and raised there we were just
talking about this before
but you are one of six kids so kind of
give me
um like where you grew up and um
your family and then talk about lebanon
i want to hear about
what was the culture like there what are
the values what are the expectation
levels
what are the struggles what's beautiful
about it um
take me like i want to understand what
lebanon was like and what your childhood
was like
so my earliest memories in lebanon were
of me sitting on our balcony
with my grandma so we would have the
power there only
you only get power like four hours a day
and then it turns off and then you get
it
so alternates basically and you get it
for half of the day
and so every other night especially in
the summer
you could sit outside and look at the
stars and we lived on a mountain and we
were surrounded by mountains
and my earliest memories were of me
sitting with my grandma
and listening to stories from her just
you know stories about some of them were
religious but some of them were
you know stories about her and her kids
my
uncles and my aunts and so those were my
earliest memories
um and then i remember growing up and
my mom and dad would travel a lot to
canada to stay with my siblings who
so long story short my five siblings
were born like right after each other
and then um eight years later i was born
so there was a big age gap between me
and them
and so you know my sister who's the
oldest in the family moved here when i
was three years old
she moved to canada when i was three
years old so i don't have many memories
with my siblings
so when when they all came here my
parents
started coming to visit them and i would
live with whichever relative
could take care of me at the time and i
know my parents had the best intentions
with that
i never doubted that you know to them it
was just like we're throwing her
wherever
i think they truly trusted that this was
the best thing to do
and so i just remember this feeling of
being out of place and just
being quiet a quiet observer i was just
constantly looking at the adults around
me
and just learning from them and i
remember
learning also from a very young age to
again
derive that feeling of i'm good enough
by who i pleased or whether i did well
in school
um is that where you got the praise was
when you did those things
yeah so in school i was uh
i was this the kid that the principal
would bring up to the front of the
school and say
i want everyone to be like her so there
was
and i was i was i was genuinely a good
child like i was not i i didn't try to
misbehave in any way
it wasn't appealing to me at all i
always i remember always trying to do
the right thing
but i also remember only deriving
whether i was good or not
whatever that meant from those comments
and um and yeah i just i just remember
it
like in black and white to be honest um
the culture there
we were just talking about this like
there were many things that i didn't
even
start reflecting on until the last year
of my life to ask myself like do i
really believe this and where did this
way of thinking come from
so where i lived was a very tiny village
and i started attending an islamic
school when i was in grade
seven and every summer even from
i think it was starting grade three or
even before that
i would go to summer camp at our local
mosque
and there were a lot of like clearly
defined
female and male gender roles and
just the idea that i had in my mind
growing up was
my life is going to be you go to school
you finish you get married you have kids
and you
you work a job that allows you to live
that kind
of life so that was the trajectory i had
in my mind and i know many people from
several cultures have that
but in my culture there's a lot of shame
attached to what a girl does or what she
doesn't do
or how she behaves or doesn't behave
like i remember when i started writing
and putting my writings out there
um a clear comment from a relative um
you know but you're a girl she said that
to me and she said like that other
people
but you're a girl you know but you're a
girl you can't
and and i was bringing up the point of
you know look at all these other poets
who are doing this stuff and so i
brought up like
khalid who's a huge lebanese poet very
celebrated
and she said but you're a girl like
people are now
knowing what your feelings are and and
you shouldn't be like how are you gonna
get married like who's gonna
want to marry you and because i was
so what is the role of a lebanese
woman or wife or even
a child
i wouldn't say that it's a hundred
percent
a certain thing because i know there are
people who
are way more progressive but from
where i came
your role was to again you know you
finish school if that
and then you get married and have kids
and
um you know your best shot is getting a
teaching job because that allows you to
you know stay with your kids um
but i wouldn't say again there are
several areas in lebanon where
people are a lot more open-minded and
it's not like that
lebanon is actually one of the better
countries
in in that whole region that
does give women yeah rights yeah
one of the things that um you've done
that
i would think goes against the culture
that you grew up in was and when i first
saw you making your videos
you wore the hijab and you stopped
wearing that last year
yeah tell me about that was that a big
deal was it not was it
a big deal to others but not you i mean
yeah i would think
yeah it was a huge deal i remember
making the decision months before i
actually went forward with it
yeah because first i had to and that's
when i realized
the internalized shame i had i had to
like i had to prove to myself first
before anyone else that
i wasn't choosing to take it off because
i'm
submitting to the pressure of the world
saying like show your body i had to make
sure
right and and and i felt i couldn't
imagine walking outside with like my
neck showing
i just i couldn't imagine i felt like i
would be walking outside
naked if i were to do that it was
terrifying
and um you know that's just
me dealing with it let alone opening up
to someone saying
you know what i don't want to wear the
hijab anymore i've been wearing it since
grade
seven but i don't want to wear it
anymore and it
the questions always came like why
why do you want to take it off like
there's and so there was a hidden
um i guess motive that many were trying
to
feed me saying things like you only want
to take it off because
you want to show your body because you
um you know you you want to engage in
certain behaviors that good girls don't
engage in
and so you're you're something is
rotting on the inside
yeah and so i that that affected me
quite a bit
yeah yeah i would think that there's you
know
makes you question things probably and
but the best thing was it made you check
in with yourself
as to what you really wanted to do yeah
so i guess
as much as the question is why did you
want to take it off
is why do you wear it in the first place
why why is that part of culture in the
first place
so in grade seven when i wore it that's
when i started going to
is that where everyone starts or is that
just when you started i mean does it
what's the normal what's the yeah so the
norm is if you
want to follow religious guidelines you
would wear it a girl would wear it when
she
hits puberty and um
again what does that mean i mean like
does that mean when you get boobs or
like what does it mean when you're hit
you go oh wow so everyone knows when you
get your period that's
awesome that's not revealing at all
like that's when it becomes an
obligation
basically and in the most traditional
forms of the religion there are people
who will tell you no that's not the case
i always have to be careful because i
don't want to
offend anyone i know sure that
several people who believe in the muslim
faith will tell you
no that's a different interpretation but
that's where i came from right that's
how it was for me right
right is that you wear it once you get
your period right and
um all of the girls in my class wore it
and
i just you were considered like
a good girl if you wore it you know like
that was a celebrated thing to do if
if we had first of all we had to wear it
during school
all day you could take it off when you
get home but you had to wear it at
school it was part of the uniform
but it was made into such a big deal if
you wore it
and i just i just wanted to fit in and i
wanted to look like my older sister who
wore it and i remember clearly when i
first put it on my dad took me aside and
said are you sure this is something you
want to do
because it's a big responsibility and i
said yes
i i want to most of the women around me
wore it so i didn't see a problem
and then i even remember right before i
moved to canada
my dad took me aside and said i know
you're a very sensitive person
you're going to a new country where
people are going to judge you for the
way you look
if you want to take your hijab off take
it off and i said no i want to wear it
like i just
i didn't imagine that it would be hard
in any way it had been part of my
identity for a while so
judgment is such a common thing for
anything and so
i would imagine that just as much as you
know you
you don't want to be judged for wearing
it you don't want to be judged for not
wearing it you also don't judge anyone
else for wearing it or for not wearing
it it's merely a
personal choice so um did you but did
you feel like
because i mean this is common with no
matter who we are or if
any of us are different or something
that even just looks different about us
did you feel misjudged
when you wore it because it wasn't the
norm
did it when i came to canada yeah
i i honestly was so unaware
of it being a problem
and that goes to show you how invisible
i
i felt at the time i just if people
didn't look
good i didn't want anyone to look anyway
people didn't talk to me
good i didn't want to be spoken to
anyway i was in survival mode when i
came here
i first realized that it was a problem
when i was 19 years old on my way to
university and i clearly remember an
older gentleman sitting
at right at the back of the bus and he
was like he was bigger and like tall
and full of tattoos and he kept staring
at me the whole way
and i was wearing a long jean skirt and
a white
shirt that had little pink and blue
flowers on it and a white hijab
and i remember i loved that skirt
because i inherited it from my sister
and i was happy i was in a good mood and
then
he stood up to get off the bus and he
just looked at me
as he was stepping outside and said you
know you're in canada you don't have to
dress like that
and i just looked down and started
bawling my eyes out
and the woman in front of me turned
around and said i'm so sorry he
shouldn't have spoken to you that way
so that was my the first time
that i understood fully
this is a problem that to some people
and so i i remember
going home that day and asking myself
like why do i wear this
yeah you know and do i want to wear it
and to me at the time it was a decision
of
it was do i choose courage and say
this has been part of my identity for so
long
and i'm not going to take it away just
so that i could please people's eyes or
do i
give in and take it off and just blend
in and
and you know be happy that way and so i
chose courage at that point and said
i'm going to continue wearing it because
to me this is a statement that says
yeah like you don't have the right to
dictate for me what i need to look like
just
so that you don't treat me that way
right yeah i want to talk about judgment
for just a second just because i think
it's such a universal thing and i'm
guilty of it i
i judge things every single day and
i do my best to try and correct it and
try and think the best
and retrain my brain to not do it but
it's it's a co it happens
so why why do we judge like what do you
think was going through that
that guy's mind when he told you that
why do we judge
i think we judge because we have our own
definition
on the inside of what's right and wrong
and
when we have it's kind of like you put a
barrier
um in front of that because you don't
want to come to terms with the fact that
perhaps your way of thinking is not
the right way of thinking so you want to
defend your own beliefs in a way
and so that's how that comes across
instead of saying
like why do i have a problem with her
being covered
you're just saying her being covered is
a problem and i need to do something
about it to change it
so it's it's a it's it's a level of
denial
that about your own beliefs and that
maybe they need to change
i think that's part of judgment i also
think part of judgment
is wanting to feel better about yourself
and by by putting someone else down
and seeing the reaction on their face
and seeing that you have
power in a way over that person
because you just got to them and you
know that's
there's a poem in sparks of phoenix
where i say never wish them pain
that's not who you are wish them healing
that's what they need and i really
think that way towards anyone who judges
me because
i think they need healing it's not that
i could easily
i could have easily you know stood up
that day and chased after him and said
something terrible
um you know at the time seeing a tattoo
to me based on my beliefs that was a sin
like you don't get a tattoo but
i won't show you mine no but i don't
think that way anymore but i was 19 and
i had been in canada for three that
would have been the equivalent of the
reciprocation yeah of the judgment
yeah exactly a tattoo would have meant
that person is going to hell right
that's what it would have meant i could
have said that to him
but i didn't think of it because i
didn't look at people to classify them
in a certain way like you're right
you're wrong you're going to heaven
you're going to hell
you know that's not who you are no i
want to read another poem um
i want to talk about uh so i want to
talk about home
um home is one of those things for me
that
hits home whether it's been
home as in living i've lived in a lot of
places
and um i'm one that tends to move for
relationships and
and then there's of course that next
level of it which is building homes in
someone else and i feel like that was
really
one of those videos that uh and it
i think you said it you did a ted talk
too right and i remember watching the
ted talk a few times and you talked
about that
and not building homes and other people
and
man that was really powerful so um i
want to read
uh i want to read one of your writing
um and then dive into it
you were my home why was it so hard for
me to let go of you
i had no home and with that i was
content
because i never knew what it felt like
to feel home
to feel like home sorry i never knew
what it felt like to feel like home
so you built a home for me and i finally
felt like i belonged
all of my scattered pieces suddenly came
together
somewhere i put my heart to sleep as you
cradled my worries away
i woke up one day cold abandoned without
a roof on top
without windows or walls without you
and you wonder why i'm unable to let you
go
before you i never knew what a home was
you gave me a taste of heaven and with
your hands you took
it away once you enter heaven
you can never live again the same way
home is a home is is so many meanings so
what does home mean to you what
what was i mean talk to me about that
that poem in particular maybe start
there
i wrote that poem after
a terrible heartbreak that i went
through
and the best way i could explain it was
that i felt homeless i felt
like i had tasted a feeling
that i i knew i was longing for
my whole life without knowing what it
was
but it was that feeling of home which is
feeling like you belong unconditionally
just as you are like you don't have to
beg someone
for their love like you don't have to
you know
change parts of who you are to be
welcome and accepted
and that was the first time in my life
that i had felt that way
and it it was an addictive feeling
and so i i that's why i wrote at the end
once you enter heaven you can never
live again the same way to me that
feeling of home
was heaven
did you build a home in that person yes
what did that teach you
it taught me to never build a home in
someone else it taught me that i needed
to start building a home within myself
it taught me i would say the most
important lesson it taught me is
you know the feeling of emptiness that
you feel when someone walks away
you know you feel like i've given so
much of myself
and i put it inside that person and
they're gone and you just
feel like you feel like you're a loose
leaf in the wind yeah
and you just don't you certainly you are
you don't know exactly you don't matter
you don't you don't you feel like you're
you have nothing that grounds you you
don't know who you are
all you're focused on is that person
and you think that just because they
walked away with so much of what you
invested in them
that they're the only person who could
give it back to you
and that's what i like hung onto for so
long
until i realized that
that feeling of emptiness was
okay because i really did
put so much of myself into that person
and my intention wasn't to feel empty
my intention was to genuinely give that
person the love that i felt
towards him and my
intention wasn't to deplete myself
my intention was i'm investing this in
someone who i deeply care about so i can
come home at the end of the day to these
things that i'm putting there
so that feeling of emptiness is real
and so where do you go from there and
that's when it hit me if i'm
really fixated on what i gave that
person then that in a way makes me
selfish because i want to take
back what i gave instead why don't i
focus on the fact that
i was the source of that love i was the
source of that respect i was the source
of that kindness
that i gave to that person that i
invested in that person that i
built a home in that person with if i
am the source then i can recreate that
yeah from within myself for myself
moving forward why would i beg someone
to give me something back
when i am the one who had the ability to
create it in the first place
why put myself at the mercy of a
recipient
of something that i created that was the
biggest realization i made
how did you build a home in yourself
what were some of the things that you
did what do you do on a regular basis
maybe it's
every day maybe it's every month
to build a home within yourself you have
to start by understanding
where you are you have to start by
understanding the value of a home
and you have to start by understanding
yourself as a person
because you can know everything there is
to know
about self-love because that's the first
thing you hear
like when you get out of a relationship
or out of anything any any
difficult circumstance in your life
people say well you need to focus on
self-love
you need to know what your worth is and
i was at a point in my life
after that where i thought i knew what
my worth is and i
because i could talk to you about it i
could tell you
i would never accept this kind of
treatment if a guy spoke to me that way
or if someone at work spoke to me that
way i would never accept it
you can learn i i come from a teaching
background right
i can teach my students i can put a
lecture up on
the screen i can test them and make sure
that they've memorized
something or that they've understood a
concept
but the most important thing is whether
they will apply it or not
whether they know how to apply it or not
so
many times they don't they'll do really
well on knowledge they'll do really well
on you know problem solving but when it
comes to application they don't know how
to apply it and that's
the problem it's the same thing with our
lives right you can know everything
there is to know about worth but
well that's the conscious yeah right the
conscious you can go oh i learned that
that's good oh yeah don't take that
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna put up
with that but the subconscious the
autopilot kicks into gear and it says
no we repeat this pattern yes this is
where you're safe yes we repeat
even if it doesn't make sense even if it
feels horrible
we repeat the pattern because that's
what's familiar
exactly so there's two parts one how do
you
find out who you are
and then what are your routine rituals
to reprogram because that's the
important part right it's like with
judgment
i think to myself yes i judge every day
but i used to judge and not think
anything of it
and then i was a much more negative
person
now i judge less
and when i judge i try and correct it
right because that's the
reprogramming thought of correction and
then go you look and you look at
something you go oh wow they
you know they're doing their best you
know what like wow that person was
really rude you got who ha
you have no idea i have no idea what
kind of day they've had and you try and
correct it and then over time you
you have less corrections and you're a
more positive person
um that's how i try and do it but how
first off is how do you know who you are
because that's the hardest thing the
hardest thing to truly know
who the hell you are because you're
consciously
you're always bombarded with your phone
with looking at pictures of other people
what other people say
you're you have family around you have a
partner that's judging
that has you you know you slip into your
routines again with family
culture telling you what's cool what's
not cool um
there's so many things that that that
make it really hard to know who
you are minus everything else
so how do you do that
you know who you are by listening
to yourself by staying silent
and just allowing your brain
your heart and your soul to speak to you
because what does your phone do
it's it distracts you it numbs your
feelings
what do your family relatives community
what do they all do
they are numbing techniques they are
distractions they are
you know anything like i just want to do
anything
except for sit with myself right yeah
and i was like that for
for a long time i would just i would go
to events
or i would you know go sit in a crowded
place just because i didn't want to be
alone with my thoughts wow
you sit in silence and you listen
because those voices from inside of you
those are your beliefs about yourself
talking to you telling you this is what
you think of yourself
just like for example after a rejection
that you go through
think of the first things that come to
your mind
you're not good enough yeah absolutely
you're not worthy
and do you want to listen to those
voices no you don't
you want to go to listen to a friend who
tells you
he's a jerk or she's a jerk or you
deserve
better you want to listen to all those
things but are you really solving are
you going to the root of the problem
and working on it you know i had a
friend and he's here right now
who a few months ago i called him and i
said like my heart
physically hurts it hurts on the inside
i can't
do this anymore i can't take this pain
anymore and it was after a heartbreak
and he said to me
you know i think the problem is much
deeper than that it's much deeper than
this person
your this problem is not about this
person
because you've experienced it before
multiple times and you come to the same
realization that tells you you're not
worthy of love
you're not worthy of belonging you need
to go to the root of the problem
and work on it and that was like
such a powerful wake-up call for me
because it's true it wasn't that person
it was my belief about myself
that i'm not worthy of love that's what
hurts
it's not someone walking away yeah it's
that
i truly and genuinely didn't believe
that i was worthy of love that's what
hurts
you are out of resonance with love which
is what we all are pure love and we
let all of these other things interfere
with our the resonance that wants to
happen so
i feel like that's an extremely great
way to explain
how you can recognize when something
you need to deal with something because
it doesn't feel good
it's out of resonance it's a negative
it's a lower vibration feeling trying to
meet you where you are which is love
like goodness and
like but we get it messed up we get it
muddled
can you get can you listen can you
understand that about yourself without
taking the time to listen
to yourself you can you can go to a
therapist
and you can speak to them for hours
but what you speak is often
not a hundred percent
you know reflective of what you're
feeling on the inside because when you
speak in a way you want to be an
advocate for yourself
and at the same time you don't want that
person who's sitting across
from you to think any less of you or to
judge you
you have to sit with yourself and
say i believe this about myself
or this is my way of thinking this is
what's going through my mind and if it
hurts
i'm going to cry yeah and if if it if it
requires that i
distance myself from everyone around me
for a couple of weeks then i'm going to
do it
and if it requires that i have to make
changes in my life
i'm going to do it so it begins by
listening just just do this at home
for five minutes i challenge you close
your eyes
and just don't have any sound or any
noise around you
for five minutes put a timer on your
phone you think it's easy but it's not
it's actually
so difficult because you're it's
it's kind of like you know muddy water
that you've allowed to settle for a long
time and now all of a sudden you're
shaking it
and sometimes you don't know
exactly what those what that mud is
telling you or what it is
but it feels like there's a hurricane on
the inside
you're so uncomfortable with your own
silence
and that is that's the beginning of your
awakening to who you are yeah
and then the hard work begins because
now you need to change those beliefs
and you change them by asking yourself
why do i believe this about myself
like what has happened we talked about
this earlier too
what has happened earlier in my life
or even more recently in my life
that has proven this belief to me about
myself
and if i could go back to that moment
say
a certain moment made you believe that
you know um you're not good enough to
become
a doctor let's just say that go back to
that moment
and ask yourself was that actually
true like was what i felt and that
belief that i formed about myself
was that actually true or did i just
take someone's word for it or did i just
amplify
a tiny feeling and allow it to become
a solidified belief have you been able
to
break it down and get to not only the
root
the root emotion that comes up that's
the problem but the
maybe the person yes
yeah i would say it's it's been multiple
people
to be honest because
once you form a certain belief about
yourself
and it becomes deeply rooted within you
whether you're aware of it or not you're
you go out into the world
and you search for proof that that's
true
oh my god yes i do you do so if you
believe that you're not
good enough you wake up in the morning
and you leave your place
and you're constantly looking for you
know if that person didn't smile back at
me
you file it in that folder that says
you're not good enough you say see
but here's a revolutionary thought
what if you left your place in the
morning saying
i am good enough and i'm going to look
for every confirmation
that i am good enough do you see how
that
shifts everything so instead of
viewing things negatively or viewing
people's behaviors who each and every
one of them has their own things that
they're going through
to mean something about yourself you're
celebrating
everything that's good out there and
saying see like this is
you know that's an incredible challenge
and it's not
it does it sounds exciting like i think
that's what i'm going to do tomorrow in
fact that's what i'm going to do
starting what everybody should do
because that's honestly that's actually
my
that's actually my um my core belief
that i have a problem with is that i'm
not enough
so i look for evidence just like you
said
i look for evidence in every thing in my
life
relationships all that kind of stuff
about
how i'm not enough and
because you want to validate it because
your ego says no no we live here we live
with this hormone
we live with this chemical reaction that
happens in the body when we find reasons
why we're not
good enough and we're not enough and it
feels good and i need you to repeat i
need you to press the button i need you
to keep pressing the button
and there's this is stuff that's beyond
the scope of my knowledge to be able to
just dump on you guys so easily but
there's
there's a chemistry to all of this um
in fact the episode that's coming out
this week with um joe dispenza
he goes into a lot of this about the
chemical reaction in the brain
but we do it's like a it's like a drug
we we're chemically programmed to repeat
those
things to ourselves because it feels a
certain way and there's a response that
happens
um but i love it's like it's a
reprogramming
yeah every day you could just wake up
and say today i'm going to go out and
whatever
whatever it is that is your insecurity
is to go out and go i'm going to find
evidence
why i'm the other right why i am good
enough or why i
am smart enough or why i am pretty
enough or what change
ever it is that is a reprogramming that
will
change your life yes it's life-changing
seriously just try it for a day
wow go out whatever belief it is that
you have about yourself
make it the opposite and say just for
one day because it's easier for us to
take challenges on that don't
you know make us feel like we're
stepping outside of our comfort zone for
too long
say i'm just gonna do it for a day or
even just for an hour
and go out consciously thinking in your
mind
i am looking for proof of the opposite
of that core belief that i have
and you'll start seeing things
differently i was going to go back to
one of the points you were making
earlier about why we keep
doing certain things we talked about how
it's familiar
but you know say for example you
you know you're used to checking
someone's social media someone who's
really like an
ex someone who's really not good for you
social stalking yeah
but it you know say
you're checking and you see that that
person is liking someone's pictures and
it
bothers you you know but why do you keep
going back to check
when you know that's going to be the
answer
even though you know you're going to
feel terribly evident
why do you do it it's because that
confirmation within you
that's like see i told you so in a way
you feel like you've proven something to
yourself
and i used to be like that right now
i follow that up with a question i tell
myself
so what if you prove that to yourself
what will you do based on that so what
what if you do prove that someone
you know is liking someone else's
pictures which somehow you translate in
your mind
to mean that you're not good enough what
if you do discover that
you know you go on social media and you
do discover that they're still doing
that and you're confirming that to
yourself every single day
so what what does that mean and what are
you going to do about it once you
discover it because there
should be some form of action you think
that you're going to feel
you know like i've i've proven this to
myself you're going to feel great
right but you don't so i always say so
what will you do after you discover
you know that it's a confirmation or not
what are you going to do
and when i focus on that question it's
like reverse psychology i don't even do
the behavior that's going to lead me up
to it because the answer to that so what
is
i can't do anything there's nothing that
i can do about it or just feel worse
which yeah why would anyone willingly
sign up for that
yeah don't willingly you don't
consciously sign up for that you
subconsciously sign up for that
so if you can activate the conscious
which is what it sounds like you're
talking about
you can start to overpower the
subconscious
instincts yes to find evidence
from the subconscious to keep feeding
these insecurities yes
powerful fantastic i want to read
another i want to read another
um another poem the next pain
well this was the so this is the first
book mine platter is the first book
and um i actually want to show you uh
i'm not going to read it all because you
know you wrote me a message but
um but
this was sent to me with a beautiful a
beautiful message
and najwa said uh that you know i hope
that we get to meet
now we only know each other virtually
but i hope to meet you one day
and this was a couple of years ago so
we've
manifested this yes um uh but i want to
read about another one about healing i
just think it's really wonderful to
you know read some of these so people
can get i mean i have tons of folds in
these books because they just are
meaningful things and
some of them are things that i wanted to
read for you guys and some of these were
just things that really are meaningful
to me that are a little bit more
personal
um but um it's about healing because i
feel like what we've been talking about
is healing and how we can
um be an alchemist in our life
and change what was what feels bad into
something that feels good
i will heal i sincerely hope that your
soul
finds peace you broke me
but it was only because you were broken
i will heal because i know that i need
to
but i worry that you will never realize
that you are in need of healing hurt
people hurt people
yes right they do
[Music]
and i think that that's you know i feel
like that speaks to that
part of you which is saying that's not
who you are
to judge or to react it's not who you
are
so um but it's it's our own you can't
make someone do something i feel like
this is
this is common with anything you can't
make someone think differently act
differently
they might temporarily do it because
they feel that there's some kind of a
consequence or they're on the hot seat
but real change does not happen unless
you decide to make the real change
so that was a poem to me that recognizes
that you know what i realized that i
needed to change and i needed to
let you go um
but i actually still have compassion for
you because
you need help too we all need help
it's really powerful i think looking
back at that poem i
i know that i wrote it at a point when
[Music]
i was still in so much pain
but i couldn't bring myself
to be angry with that person for hurting
me
the way that he did yeah and
i i just worked by
my my true core which was
you know even though i know that you
might never realize
that you've made terrible mistakes in
your life
i i do sincerely hope that you find
healing
i do sincerely hope that you heal one
day
and i was hurting so much when i wrote
that but it brought me a certain level
of relief because i was not choosing
the same you know in in mind platter i
wrote don't give them a taste of their
own medicine they already know what it
tastes like
give them a taste of your own medicine
you know if they
lied to you let your medicine be honesty
if they made you cry let your medicine
make them smile i was working
by the words that i truly believed in
which was you know i didn't receive my
closure
i i you know no one said
oh you have this because it wasn't a
physical wound it was a wound on my soul
even though no one had seen that at that
point no one
no one acknowledged it or validated it
but i
knew i was bleeding on the inside
i was still able to say
you know i wish you healing i i hope
that you heal
and the the relief that that brought me
was i'm not allowing
someone who is not me to make me someone
who i'm not
and i'm very grateful that i was able to
see things that way
instead of you know wanting to to hurt
that person the same way
that that he hurt me yeah
that brings me to another concept which
is to me it feels like there's a part of
it in that it's just letting go
right how did you know how do you know
to let go of a bad relationship
i mean i've read so many of your poems
and i'm like oh gosh that's the reason
yes
you read that and you're like oh why
didn't i see that i'm so stupid
um but in the middle of it it's hard but
why is it so hard to let go
why can't we just let go it's not good
for us
because if you talk to a friend right
you know everything there's a scenario
like you know what you would tell your
friend
you're like yeah girl you need to leave
um
i i don't know what you're thinking he's
obviously
you know you could do so much better and
you know then the tables get turned
and you're there acting it all out it's
kind of what i reacted to earlier
when i was fumbling around um and then
the tables get turned on you
and someone says to you danica
what would you say to me
if i said all these things and i was
like oh [ __ ]
you gotta go yeah i said so hard but
then you can't even do that
even if you even after you realize it i
mean the last one took five years so
yeah
so it's hard to let go so i
before i get into letting go this is
what i'm going to say
self-love to me is imagining
the person who you love the most okay so
imagine one or two people who you love
the most
put yourself next to them so
if one of these loved people to you as
your partner
and he comes home at the end of the day
and he has a very difficult day
what would you do you would probably you
know
do everything it takes to make sure that
he's feeling better you would give him
time
and space if he wanted that you would
you know put on a show that you know he
likes or do something that you know he
likes
do you do that for yourself or do you
come home and say i had a rough day well
it's
it's you know whatever it's just like
any other day i'll just deal with it
another time
you you put yourself last you put
taking care of yourself as being a
selfish
act because there's someone else who
needs your love or your
time or and it's like they're all more
worthy of
all of those great things that you have
to offer than you are
right self-love is to say
i will not accept less than what i would
give
my most loved one because whether i like
it or not
i am my most loved one
i am my number one priority i am my
number one responsibility
so that's why when you're sitting with a
friend you can tell her
you need to let that guy go but
when you're sitting with yourself you
make up every excuse
possible and you also step into that
role of
but you know i know all of these things
about
psychology and you know there has to be
an excuse
the bottom line is you are not treating
yourself
as one of your loved ones you are
treating yourself
as one of those people who are on the
margins of your own life
you know you're putting someone who is
clearly hurting you at a higher level
than you are
you are choosing to give that person a
chance
multiple chances yeah knowing that
you're hurting yourself
you're choosing that over telling
yourself
danica what if this time you're actually
wrong
what if this exception to the rule that
you genuinely believe is the case
what if it's wrong i know it's been you
know the pattern in your life in the
past but what if
you know this way of thinking is wrong
you're not even giving yourself
the benefit of the doubt that you're
giving that person who is hurting you
over and over and over and it all goes
back to self-love
where do you put yourself in your own
life yeah
now when you master that you can let go
you can draw boundaries you can make
sure
that no one ever gets comfortable
disrespecting you
or not giving you the love that you
deserve but you have to start at that
point
when you get to a point where you're so
deep in a relationship that's
toxic any kind of relationship whether
it's at work or
or a romantic relationship or with
family members
when you get to a point where you say
i can't do this anymore and what am i
going to do and
it that's not where you are like you
don't have to just look at that moment
you have to go back
and say what got me here because you
know what
there were red flags i just chose not to
see them
right right if if you think about it
every person that you meet
within the first few hours or a few days
or a few weeks
they've already shown you certain parts
of who they are
but you just that's insightful you
silence think about them in the
beginning are they really any different
not i mean like on some level that first
inc that first like
snapshot of kind of what it really
doesn't
yeah doesn't change that much there's a
poem in the nectar of pain where i say
it is not their true colors that you
suddenly see
their true colors have always been there
it is your eyes that colored them with
kindness
so it goes back to you see the best in
people
and that doesn't make you a bad person
or naive
or it's not a weakness it's a beautiful
thing
to be able to see the best in a person
but you can see the best in a person
and draw a line and say if this is going
to hurt
me if this is going to violate my
boundaries
i'll still color you with kindness but
from a distance
i'm not allowing you more women to my
life i'm not falling in love with the
potential
that you have i'm going to see you as
you are
i think that then it takes that bravery
to stand your ground right
i mean like we think to ourselves that
if something goes away whether it's a
person or a job that
somehow will be less
or things will get worse but
truth never makes things worse honesty
never makes things worse
it's going to come out eventually anyway
so i've said for
a while you know whatever someone really
truly thinks or feels
let it all come out if that's what you
think if you're going to leave me over
something silly like that i better just
go ahead and do it right away because um
it's ridiculous so you know things like
that like just get there because the
truth
the truth will set you free it will make
you happy and it will always come out
eventually and so
delaying the inevitable only makes
things more difficult
um so facing them is the hard part
but also know that if someone if someone
if you're not right for someone else
they're also not right for you
right like if they don't really want you
at the high at the at your fullest
then you are choosing to see all the
best things and ignoring those things
that
are really not enough for you and don't
fit
and it doesn't mean everybody is enough
for them on their own and for someone
else eventually but
it doesn't mean this this person this
relationship is perfect
right don't be scared that something
goes away because something better
is on its way and i think that actually
let me uh i think i'm going to re i'm
going to read letting go because this is
this is that yeah from yeah because i
think that this says this exact thing
which is something that
you know for me letting go has been
thank you has been a real common theme i
had to deal with letting go when it came
to even my job you know
when it came in 2017 i let go of a hell
of a lot of things all within about
three days including where i live my
relationship and my job
i wouldn't recommend that um it was a
really heavy weekend
november of 17 was rough uh
but um you know it's
letting go is is one of those things and
you have to i
i'm scared like anyone else when
something is about to change or
something might go away and something
that's familiar you know we get really
comfortable and familiar
and we've existed there so we think it's
safe um
but i do have the i do have the
awareness
to say to myself that it could maybe be
better than i could ever imagine
the universe has everything that you
could ever want waiting for you
if you'll just say yes to the truth and
what feels in resonance
including the way you feel about
yourself and once you finally rise to
the occasion
of who you are those people that are not
serving you in the way that they need to
be
fall away and you don't want them
anymore because you've now seen yourself
in a new light and you won't put up with
that anymore
we can't treat the other we can't treat
others and see others unless we see
ourselves for our true colors right so
we treat others as we treat ourself
so it's a process
and i go through it constantly but
here's letting go and this is just one
that
really resonates with me because i also
think there's another level of this
which is the difference between
quitting and letting go and that's what
i had to really realize with my job was
that i'm not
quitting because it didn't go right or
i'm not going to be at this team
anymore i had to realize to myself and
be honest with myself and
i remember the day i told my dad i don't
really love racing and he said i know
and i was like
why didn't you tell me why didn't you
tell me
um why did i feel so scared to say that
and um uh but i i had to be honest with
myself
and um and so i had to learn
that i was letting go i wasn't quitting
um
i did it for 27 years i would have quit
a lot earlier if i really hated that
much but uh
um so here we go so we often attach
letting go to negativity
because we take it as giving up and
giving up as a sign of weakness
that's not always true sometimes letting
go can be as positive as holding on
and sometimes holding on can be as
negative as letting go
letting go of what makes you miserable
is the right decision
to make because while one opportunity
that you're holding on to
makes you cry your heart out another
opportunity is patiently waiting for you
it is patiently waiting for you to let
go
of what you have what you have and hold
on to this new opportunity
when you let go of what you have do it
the right way
don't let go feeling weak don't let go
feeling like you've done
anything but your absolute best
don't let go feeling like you were not
worth the opportunity
it was not meant to be worth your pain
although it may have been painful
think deeply into the purpose that made
you take that opportunity
and if you've achieved that purpose then
take pride in it
give yourself credit and don't ever let
anybody put you down
let go feeling like the biggest winner
and let lost go home with the
opportunity that never appreciated you
reflect learn move on hold on to the
next exciting thing that the world opens
up for you
and put your best forward for your best
will never
let the inner you down ever i think that
says it so well
so well so powerful a letting go such a
concept such a hard one yet such a great
one to grasp once you can understand
the difference and again feeling into
that resonance with you
i want to read one more and this is from
sparks of phoenix
and and then i want to ask you a really
uh you know some final final question
about just
the big things that make a difference in
your life um so this is about self-worth
it's much shorter my home will never
welcome me
if i don't welcome myself
so what are the three biggest lessons
that you've learned so far in your life
i learned that she's 29
i i didn't know in your 29 years tell me
the three biggest things that you've
learned
the first one has to be
that no obstacle that comes my way
no heavy weight that comes my way
is meant to weigh me down that's why i
wrote these mountains that you are
carrying you were only supposed to climb
nothing that comes my way is meant to
you know make me stay in my spot or make
me as
as small as i feel in the moment
that weight of the pain
is meant to be felt the opposite is
meant to be felt
the opposite level of success or rising
and that's why i wrote sparks of phoenix
because i went through the burning and
turning to ashes and i
rose as a phoenix as a result of that as
as someone knew as a result of that so i
i believe that any struggle that's
thrown your way
could be what stops you in your life and
keeps you stuck there for 20 or 30 years
but it could also be that what propels
you
to become the best you that you could
possibly be
and talking about letting go you don't
let go of a relationship
because you're afraid of what if i don't
find
the same person what if this is the best
that i could do what if i never feel
that feeling i felt before
what if i'm alone for the rest of my
life what if this what if that it's
always the
what if the worst thing could happen but
what if the best thing could happen
you know no weight that comes your way
no struggle no
pain is meant to keep you where you are
it's meant to elevate you
it's meant to there's there's a poem at
closer to the end of sparks of phoenix
where i say
look down at your pain all the way from
the sky
look how small it is you're meant to
rise above it to the point where you
look at it and you say oh wow
i actually experienced so much pain
because of that
so that's many lessons in one these
mountains that you are carrying you were
only supposed to climb
another big lesson and these are lessons
i'm just thinking of now in the moment
you know where i am as a person um
is just own who you are
you know in sparks of phoenix i wrote
just as you've owned your pain
fully own your healing like own yourself
don't say i i am the way that i am
because of this
and this and this and this and keep it
at that
you say i am the way that i am or i am
who i
am because of all of these things
but who do i really
want to be now and who is this person in
contrast to that person who i'm
attaching
all these labels and experiences to and
what do i need to do to come from that
to this you know own who you
are don't allow pieces of you to be
owned by experiences or people or the
way that they define you
say this is who i am you know regardless
of that this is who i am
maybe as a result of that but this is me
like stand in your own power i know it's
an overused way of
saying like be yourself but truly stand
in your own power
when i walk now i feel like there's this
bubble of power around me where
you know before i used to you know when
you asked me reflect back to that girl
who was she oh don't worry i'm going to
ask you who the girl is now too at the
beginning
walk around with oh what is she thinking
of me
and am i disappointing that person and
what the what must this behavior
if i say this what does it mean about me
it was
kind of like arrows facing at me
wherever i went
and i was you know allowing those arrows
to hit me and now i walk around with a
shield of power
that says i see you when you judge me
but i have the power to say am i going
to allow this
in or am i going to deflect it back
with the goodness that's inside of me
with the kindness that's inside of me
own who you are that good
hearted person that you are that
everyone made you believe at some point
in your life was
weak or naive own that person and say
i'm proud to be this person um i
probably said like 10 different lessons
yeah no that's beautiful i i think
that's well said so
now just finally um i asked you who the
girl was a couple of years ago in the
car
and now reflect to me who you see now
today
ah
i see myself
that's the most powerful thing is that
i was waiting for someone to see me
waiting for someone to hear me
waiting for someone to love me and now
i give those things to myself i see
myself
before and it's not easy not saying i'm
i'm like this
24 7. this is the true me who i own
before i wait for someone to see me i
see myself
before i wait somewhat for someone to
hear me
i listen to myself and i hear myself
and before i wait for someone to love me
just so i could prove to myself that i'm
worthy of being loved
i love myself i say how are you loving
yourself
before you wait for it from anyone else
and once you do that for yourself
you are unstoppable your life will be
hard
but it's not harder than being
a walking question mark
that says define me
define me tell me who i am
you are defining yourself because you
know your life is hard
because you have to do it all on your
own but you
know that you are doing it and you're
not allowing
anyone to penetrate that that bubble of
power that you have around you that that
shield that's so beautiful that
still sees people and still acknowledges
what's going on and still
feels deeply but doesn't allow any of
those things
to define you yeah he said
thank you very much thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you